[Music]
Microsoft's biggest gun going into e3
this year is Project Scorpio the final
specs for Microsoft's premium console
were revealed earlier this year but we
still don't know the price and what the
finished product will look like among
other things make sure to click that
subscribe button so when we do find out
more you'll be the first to know
[Music]
a console that can run games natively at
4k and 60 frames per second sounds great
but we'll also need to see if these
games are worth getting excited for
Microsoft has already confirmed that we
won't see Halo 6 this year but there are
still a few other exclusives that should
make an appearance like crackdown 3
which was first announced at e3 2014 and
promises to be a fully destructible
sandbox tied the cloud processing sea of
thieves should also show up this year
it lets you group up with friends in a
shared world and take to the Seas as you
search for treasure and battle other
pirates but if a zombie apocalypse is
more your speed than hopefully we will
see more state of decay to state of
decay was released on the Xbox 360 back
in 2013 and featured perma death and
open-world and resource and survivor
management it was rough around the edges
but it had a lot of great ideas so
expectations for a sequel are
appropriately high
finally Microsoft has a strong India
lineup to look forward to these include
the 1930s cartoon style cuphead the road
light game below and Fulbright's next
game Tacoma obviously Microsoft has a
few announcements up their sleeve as
well here are some of our best guesses
as to what we might see I think this
year's e3 is going to be huge for
Microsoft and I think in order for them
to really win it win it I think they
need to focus on the game so when the
Xbox one was announced a few years ago
they went real hard and heavy on the
all-in-one entertainment system like
this is how it'll work with Skype you
can watch HBO on it and track things
know like we need to see the game so
especially with Scorpio coming out later
this year
Xbox need to show us that they still
have these incredible first party
studios they need to show us that they
have great deals with third-party devs
and that their games are going to look
great on the scorpio microsoft has said
that we won't be getting Halo 6 at e3
but they did mention having a little
something to show related to the Halo
franchise we don't know what exactly
that is but halo is such a big exclusive
for Microsoft that it's exactly the shot
in the arm they need to really get
people excited about Xbox again they
have a really good strength in the
Scorpio it's going to be the most
powerful console on the market when it
hits if they can show what is capable of
and a price tag that's attractive that's
going to be really good for them but the
problem they have is it lack of games
most notably exclusives so they need to
come out of the
with games that are important to people
but not just for Scorpio owners also for
existing Xbox one owners I still want to
feel like there are Xbox one games
coming out for me if I'm not willing to
immediately jump to another Xbox console
and I think that a lot of people who are
in a similar situation where they don't
want to upfront invest in another
Microsoft console having not got their
money's worth out of the previous one
will want to want more services want
more games want more exclusives so
hopefully Microsoft is thinking broadly
for all of its Microsoft and Xbox fans
instead of just the people who are
potential Xbox Scorpio or project
Scorpio buyers what I think Microsoft
need to do if they want to win this
year's e3 is just play up project
Scorpio 100% their winning formula this
year is the fact that they have the most
powerful console on the market and
that's going to be a really big deal for
people who want their games running at
the best possible fidelity it's going to
be a huge thing if Microsoft decided to
get into VR laser so I think that's the
kind of thing they need to focus on now
I don't know if this is the thing that
would make Microsoft win a three but I
would love to see a virtual reality
something from Microsoft at e3 now Sony
already has the PlayStation VR
Nintendo's kind of played with augmented
reality on smartphones Microsoft with
Project Scorpio in this more powerful
system could potentially introduce some
kind of virtual reality support and I
think would be really exciting to be at
e3 and have them announce either oculus
or HTC vive support for project Scorpio
and that's what we want to see let us
know if we missed anything in the
comments below and if you want to stay
up to date on the go check out GameSpot
now on iOS or Android it's the fastest
way to see the top ten stories of the
day thanks for watching
[Music]